welcome back to the iced coffee hour it
has been a very long time since we've
done something like this we have a lot
to catch up on lots of drama yeah we did
this is something I didn't know Alex you
sold your entire portfolio and you
didn't tell anybody we had no idea first
you go to Marge and you don't tell
anybody there's a lot of money on
ethereum and you sell everything what
happened you don't have to call me out
like that man what happened you know me
I'm running these things I'm just trying
to uh time the market
um no I didn't sell my like retirement
like portfolio you know that's just been
consistently investing but everything
that I had in Robin Hood uh which at the
time that I sold is probably like I
don't know 10 grand
I just sold it so now you could have
learned from me Alex so now I'm holding
cash so how much did you lose all time I
didn't well yeah I broke about even
that's not bad so you sold it break even
yeah I sold that break even I maybe lost
a hundred bucks okay but you sold out of
all of the positions you were holding uh
except for like two dollars of Dogecoin
and how long ago was that or like three
months ago so technically you made the
right decision no yeah yeah yeah so yeah
um my I don't this is not Financial
advice please do not follow what I do
but I'm going to be buying back in in
about uh about two months are you also
going to be selling a stock of course
now yeah so actually like if you
actually look at the shape of the
candles no I'm just kidding yeah no it's
honestly like it's my YOLO portfolio
um don't do what I did I'm just playing
around with if I lose that money I don't
care yeah uh but yeah I didn't know you
guys were gonna call me on the podcast
like I'm gonna look so sorry I thought
you're gonna tell us
[Music]
well here's the thing I feel like it's
bad luck if like I sell everything and
then I tell you because then I feel like
because then I was gonna drink yeah well
I didn't want to I didn't want to go
there but yeah that's true yeah then
Jack would solve everything and it would
catapult but so far it looks like it's
the right move
um again I'm not saying I could time the
market or anything I'm just
it's glorified uh I don't want to say
the word but G you know he gets very
lucky with okay
maybe because here's do you want to tell
the story yeah oh it's quick side
tangent yeah but I posted a Ludwig video
on my main Channel that I thought should
have done really well he's got a huge
audience I spent so much time on this
video it came out perfect and I posted
it and immediately I noticed that the
views were like a third of what they
normally would and usually for a video
like this I would expect it to not do as
well right off the get-go but never by
like never to see such a huge decline
I'm thinking about it the one thing
that's in that video is the term we
can't even say it here because I don't
want this to happen with this video
um you know when you uh when you do
something else at the casino okay so it
rhymes with rambling yeah
but when you do something compulsively a
lot and you can't control it yeah it's
it's a rambling prediction yes something
like that yes so I think because I use
that term multiple times throughout the
video I think that YouTube may have
subdued that video now this this is just
a theory we're not 100 sure but with the
looks of like how there's a lot of hate
on Twitch towards that kind of stuff it
would not surprise me if because when we
were looking at the chart when it posted
it was crazy but uh yeah aside from that
side tangent that's interesting yeah
they could have saw the captions and
then figured out from the transcript
that you said those words and it could
be Shadow it analyzes it immediately
like the the transcript of the video is
available at the time the video is
posting and we uploaded and posted as
soon as the checks were complete but I
have a feeling those checks when YouTube
goes through the video they're analyzing
what's said in the video and then they
decide from there which audiences
they're so smart of course there's
always videos that are going to have
like like there's a Joe Rogan thing that
has that in the title yeah of course
there's going to be videos that do it
and there's no way for us to tell for
sure yeah so we should actually bleep
out the word yeah okay and see it and
see if it makes it no seriously let's
bleep out the word
that rhymes with rambling
yeah okay sure I'm curious why two
months for you why is that your time
Horizon on buying back in I there's no
answer it's just a feeling yeah 100 like
at this point I'm just uh kind of
coincides with uh midterms doesn't it
Alex no no not at all
I will say though I I'm getting knocks
on my door so frequently from people
dropping off this uh political mail
they're leaving it on my car it's like I
don't live in a gated community they're
leaving on my cars they're calling me
like three times a day I cannot wait for
this time of the year to be over I get
the texts all this I get the texts yeah
oh the texture it depends on your stake
a certain States publicize the uh
the the register certain like
registration information and certain
states don't and Nevada I think is more
lenient than where I used to live I
never used to get this much bombardment
a lot I'm really surprised that it's
honestly legal to leave things at
people's doorsteps or when you're
driving and parking in like a random
parking lot how you can come back to
your car and there's a flyers all in
here man we don't have to get into the
legality of that because honestly I
don't know what's illegal and what's not
yeah I'm just because I I feel like
every time that happens I just see
litter everything it turns into the
garbage yeah so but anyways we have a
lot to catch up on because I see you're
wearing a new watch your weight loss you
took a little bit of a slower period
where you could talk about that and then
now you're kind of back into it and
you're doing really well lots of other
stuff to catch up on too because we
visited Dave Ramsey we visited Mr Beast
we visited Darman we saw all these guys
facilities and they are mind-blowing
yeah we haven't talked about it until I
tell you guys the truth about these
people do we like them or do we dislike
them the good the bad the ugly gotta
keep watching And subscribe if you
haven't done that already the new
YouTube layout have you seen it it sucks
on mobile it makes subscribing so
difficult because now when you go to a
video all the information you want to
see subscriber count it's not there
doesn't matter anymore and the Subscribe
button isn't there either you have to
click on a profile to see the profile in
order to subscribe on mobile it's so
annoying you can do anything else you
could create clips from videos but you
can't subscribe also just show the
subscriber count and the Subscribe
button that's it they also yeah I was
gonna say it's just uh the comments I
think they move the comment section now
so instead of scrolling down and
automatically reading comments which I
used to do for every video uh no now
it's suggested first and you have to
click into comments so some could say
that they're tick tockifying YouTube
yeah teach their own but let's get into
it you talking it you ticking nice yeah
nice Graham yeah good job so let's get
into it guys I've been working hard the
last two years and I thought it was
finally time to reward myself so what do
you guys think of my new watch here
I mean I like the fact that you know the
size is a good size right there it's a
really good size yeah because it would
have looked a little silly I think if
you had a tiny little watch sure uh you
have big manly wrists I think so thanks
I think it looks really nice yeah do you
think it was a good Financial investment
you know what that is Jack uh no you
don't know what it is it's Panerai oh
wow you know how much it's worth I'm
guessing
2200 or 2700 panoris are not that cheap
Jack I know but I'm probably probably
like double that Holy
well I know that panerai's are expensive
but I wouldn't have like I wasn't taking
that I was mostly talk thinking about
you're you're like
no frugally I guess in a sense what are
you trying to say I wouldn't have
expected Alex to spend so much money on
a watch but I think that's awesome you
spent more money in the aquarium are you
I actually did probably well MSRP not
like actual money I put this was
actually a gift from a fan of the
channel no way
yeah some say who was it some say that
it was actually the creator of the
channel
congratulations thanks man I think
that's awesome no no Graham gave me the
watch but
it's not real
uh
did we get you yeah that makes I mean
that makes a lot that makes more sense
no dude I mean I think it looks great
thanks you know thanks yeah it's great I
mean how much was it I don't know a
buddy gave it to me a while ago so you
didn't even buy it you know what I
didn't even know that Graham didn't buy
it but that makes a lot of sense now
yeah did you give him boxing everything
too boxing papers no no you know what he
bought it and um I either he didn't wear
it or I forget like it works fine but
it's it's so big on me that I just it
looks like a normal watch on my hand
yeah yeah I think it looks really good
oh yeah and so I mean a clone I mean I
don't know what it's worth maybe a
couple hundred bucks yeah he was saying
this is actually what's called a super
clone yeah I'm insane yeah if you're
looking at it um I was looking at
pictures online yeah it looks pretty
dang identical
um I mean maybe the band is a little bit
different but I think it looks really
good apparently it's becoming such an uh
I don't what you say epidemic of these
super clone watches they're getting so
accurate now because of the technology
what they do is they take a real watch
they scan it and they remanufacture
every bit or a fraction of the price and
then they just resell it it's basic you
know it's not a real one but is it the
same like materials and everything
probably not yeah they probably don't
use the same materials no I mean if you
put the two side by side I mean
obviously a real one's probably gonna
it's probably gonna feel heavier it's
it's gonna be more accurate it on time
it's going to be better in every way but
the movement is probably just a generic
yeah right and why doesn't Panerai find
these people in suit oh they do I mean
but but they pop up probably so fast
like whack-a-mole like you get one of
them and like 20 others pop up that's
really interesting yeah it's not worth
their time to go and pursue but it is it
is effective I did go to a wedding you
know last weekend wore this watch people
were like oh nice watch that's awesome
yeah that's all you need I didn't say
anything I was like thanks appreciate it
like yeah oh this thing oh
I just uh we're taking wedding photo
like
no so but yeah that's the watch story uh
to the weight loss story so it's been so
long that the ice coffee hour audience
does not even know that I posted a video
on my channel which uh I normally would
shamelessly plug that was a definitely a
Shameless no no but it's no no honestly
this video guys like it took a lot of
like heart and soul for me to to post
um it was the hardest thing
to post probably ever on my channel so
far and it started off with shirtless
and weighing myself it had the starting
weight that that means like a lot to me
of where where we started this journey
and I explained
like how I used to eat I explained like
just what basically was weighing me down
and and I wanted to kind of take my
biggest insecurity and put it on the
world for everybody to see and ever
since then
um I will say it has felt like a like a
weight lifted off my shoulder and I
think we started the weight loss Journey
how long has it been jacked me like
almost three months yeah I would say
close to three months close to three
months
and um I'd say the first like two months
were were pretty pretty good the last I
want to say like three to four weeks
uh was tough I mean I hit a wall at
about 30 pounds which lost about 30
pounds and I I just like hit the wall
and I didn't know what to do and I think
I just got a little bit too
comfortable I guess like it became a
routine so like the good thing now is
that I no longer go to fast food places
I think in the last three months I've
been to McDonald's once and then any
other place has been like we go to
Chipotle or something
um so now the habits have changed and
that part is pretty much I don't worry
about that now but now
I'm getting more into uh controlling
portions and
trying to introduce more more exercise
but you've broke through this recently
yeah recently but it it was so hard I
mean I was stuck
for like probably like three weeks
um and and it's
it's really hard to it's really
demotivating
um but then I kind of like think about
where we started and it better
um
and and the good part or the important
part I think that when I hit a wall I
definitely focus on at least like not
going back up
within like like four pounds you know
because it fluctuates but I think that's
that's been like the really the really
big part I think as long as I think
everybody has their own speed at which
they're going to lose weight
um and I certainly definitely want to go
faster than I have been the last month
um but I think as long as we continue to
show progress I think okay and
introducing more exercise for sure yeah
I think you need to exercise like three
times a week I think so let's go on the
treadmill 30 minutes yeah that's it and
just just do a good Pace yeah I will say
it it did slow down
when I um
when I stopped going to boxing oh yeah I
was going to boxing every every week and
I was like you should continue that yeah
and so I was thinking about finding like
just a different teacher yeah and uh
continuing it because I noticed that
correlation that as soon as I dropped
that
um and so I would do boxing once a week
and then I would shadow box one more day
a week in my home and then I was going
to the gym with graham about once yeah I
was getting so I was getting three
workouts every every week and I noticed
that as soon as I dropped that I didn't
gain weight but I the progress like was
so so slow and so uh I think I think
that that's what it was oh yeah yeah
that's the update what do you what do
you guys think I mean you've done a
really really incredible job so far
you've already lost like you said 30
pounds which is
crazy to think about because if you hold
up a 25 pound weight in a five pound for
you I'm sure if you put those on your
shoulders you'd be like oh my gosh but
that's literally what it was like to
walk three months ago for you so really
impressive I'm extremely proud of you
done an amazing job and um I think
there's only you know we can only go I
guess down from here right not up from
here because we're losing weight but he
was waiting he was waiting to say that
but yeah yeah awesome let's pivot the
subject here a little bit I'm taking my
wife to Hawaii and by me I mean my
mother-in-law gave me a wedding present
uh for our honeymoon as a trip to Hawaii
and
um I have I'm going to be doing a video
idea so tomorrow Kelsey and I are going
to be staying at the Travel Lodge uh
downtown in Vegas Vegas okay and for
those of you guys that don't know what
the Travelodge is it's rated like the
worst hotel in Vegas I think the rooms
are like thirty dollars and uh we're
gonna be
probably like the worst review how do
you get food from there do they have no
I don't think they have food they don't
have like uh but I'm gonna find you know
what I should call and ask just to see
is this your honeymoon yeah I want this
to be the first day of my honeymoon so
because I want to like
for some reason I I thought it would be
to do like
one star honeymoon versus like five star
honeymoon yeah so um because we did not
spend money on the accommodations in
Hawaii
um I took the budget that I originally
set aside for my honeymoon it's a
Travelodge
and I'm keeping the rest for myself
let's just put it towards the trail no I
took it and I I told Kelsey we could do
like uh things like excursions or
whatever so
um I'm gonna film all that and I'm gonna
post it on my channel that's cool I
think it'll be an interesting video Yeah
Jack's been Tick Tock famous now if you
guys have not been keeping up with him
Jack's been getting millions of views on
Tick Tock how many followers do you have
John 20 something thousand twenty four
thousand have you been recognized from
your Tech talks yet I have yeah I've
been recognized for my team what do they
say like like it'll happen like it's
only happened
twice and both times they were like did
you go to college
which is just like and it's it's you
know what's funny you dropped out of
college I know I dropped out of college
but the thing is like I asked people if
they went to college but I've been
posting stuff on Tick Tock people have
been really liking it it's kind of fun
for me and I really like to escape my
comfort zone and approach random people
because I definitely am not good at
doing that at all so you know two birds
with one stone escaping the comfort zone
and also growing uh a social presence on
Tick Tock I feel like why not you're
posting every day uh almost sometimes
like I go through phases where I'll post
every single day and usually that's
after I go out and film for a day so
I'll have a bunch of content and then
once the content starts to dry up then I
kind of like once every two days once
every three days I haven't posted in
probably three days right now I just
have to go out and film more but it's
really cool like I've kind of found a
way to
like a process to go viral on Tick Tock
over and over again and I'm starting to
like catch up on a bunch of different I
don't know man I see the views declining
it's a trend no it's a friend from what
do you do for a living you know Daniel
well then you got to find the next thing
right yeah yeah yeah I I have theories
on why the views have been declining but
still I'm extremely what are you serious
why the views are declining yeah because
I'm spending significantly less time on
it
like oh so you've seen a correlation
between the effort that you've put in to
the view and also the pickiness that I
have with the type of videos that I post
I still know what's going to do well but
the thing is in the beginning I didn't
uphold myself like oh I have to post
once every single day whereas like you
know in the beginning so I'd post maybe
once every three days but I'd spend so
much time on a specific video and I'd be
extremely picky on which interactions I
post on my Tick Tock and those would
consistently go viral every single time
whereas now I'm just like I'll just post
whatever and I think that as a growing
Tick Tock Creator it's probably more
important to have quali quantity over
quality to be completely honest just so
you can like get extremely familiar with
the algorithm how to post all of the
little tips it's crazy it doesn't matter
how much you post on Tick Tock like you
could post 20 videos in an hour yeah and
Tick Tock knows like which videos are
going to do well and be like just
promote it out I don't know I'm afraid
of The Tick Tock algorithm because I
know so many people on Tick Tock with
like followers from before like the big
algorithm update and now they're getting
just a couple thousand views on their
videos doing it like yeah but like so
much competition on Tick Tock yeah but
like to be in my head it just I get like
hundreds of thousands but in my head to
find somebody who has like two three
million followers and now their videos
like up there's this kid on Tick Tock
that he's the pop-up on my for you page
uh the corn kid no okay world of
t-shirts yeah you know him yeah he's his
content is funny and well people got
sick of it people got sick of it yes but
even if you did the same thing over and
over on YouTube I feel like the ratios
would still be much higher maybe because
they have more of a connection with you
but still he was posting the same type
of content I mean he's still good yeah
he still does it he's not learning his
lesson it's like you kind of gotta adapt
and evolve with the algorithm with the
times it does seem like Tick Tock it
goes through these phases where it's
like a few months it'll be one thing and
then after a few months it'll be
something else right now it's Street
interviews they're doing really really
really well but that used to be the case
too on YouTube too yeah 15 16 YouTube
used to be this uh Jack Manley it was
like capitalized on that so well and
then it just kind of went away and now
it's coming back again through Tick Tock
so you're saying Jax should just take
the next Trend that followed Street
interviews on YouTube and just do it on
tick yeah well I honestly I I'm
thoroughly enjoying the street
interviews so I I wouldn't honestly
really want to gamify it and try like I
could adapt and evolve with the
algorithm but I'm enjoying what I'm
doing currently and I think I can do it
in a way that probably will not
necessarily lose relevancy because I
think
Street interviews will always be popular
you can adapt the questions exactly you
can adapt the questions with the time
you can add little tricks and gimmicks
and stuff like that to hopefully you
know spur interest but I think it'll be
okay we'll see see well I saw that you
also were um
I don't want to say picking up checks
but you're asking girls if they would
date you yeah so how's it how's the
loved life man I deleted all my dating
apps first of all no I deleted every
single one of them yeah except Tinder I
haven't deleted Tinder well that's like
the main one well that I'm not I'm not
going on I'm not swiping I'm not
messaging people you just have Tinder
Platinum yes but that's because I paid
for it in a six month period so it's not
gonna expire until December but you
should get a refund on it on the two
days that's fine yeah so why did you
uninstall your dating apps so the reason
why I deleted them all and let me say
I'm going to delete Tinder once this
girl gets back to me the issue was I
messaged this girl and she was like
getting back to me like a lot and then I
said hey I'm deleting my apps uh here's
my phone number and she hasn't texted me
yet so I'm waiting to make sure she
texts me before I delete mine that would
be a good closer to get a number and
then just keep it open afterwards yeah
okay I'm about to delete it give me your
number yeah and then just never delete
it
I mean
it's a unique strategy it's a little bit
high risk I don't know maybe it's like a
week maybe maybe starting a relationship
uh on that no maybe that isn't the best
thing about to leave so but I mean it is
good because I don't think girls
necessarily like guys that are on dating
apps just period I think it's probably a
more unattractive trait than it is
attractive one but yeah I deleted all of
them so yeah so you just think it's I
thought it wasn't really serving me in
my life sure I thought it was more of a
negative than a positive at a certain
time it was more of a positive than a
negative back when I was actually like
utilizing them I kind of slowed down
where I wasn't really spending much time
on them I would swipe just for the
gratification of swiping and getting
matches but I wouldn't follow through
with actually messaging and trying to
set up dates and stuff like that and it
was a wasting my time even though I
wasn't spending much time on it and B is
just like mental you know thought
process that I didn't necessarily need
to have have you thought about just
Outsourcing your Tinder no I would I
thought you did that Jack no I was
thinking about doing it I know I thought
I thought you had I only had JJ do some
swiping for you no no I asked JJ for
advice sometimes on my messages but I
definitely have I think we all
contributed to some of those messages oh
easy yeah it was a group effort we'd sit
there at the table like five of us be
like all right we're gonna craft this
message say no don't use that word
Graham thinks he's so craft no no I'm
saying like we'd be like no don't use
that word in the message oh yeah oh like
oh I had this emojis is so smooth he
really thinks he's smooth
Jackie's so many emojis and smiley faces
that's the linger nowadays no it's not
the letters yes it is
like 20 emojis in a little sentence yeah
that's a little much but the thing is if
you're trying to convey how you're
feeling in a message nothing better than
emoji and I think what a girl likes is
the fact that you don't care and you're
fine throwing the Emojis out there
you're fine using exclamation points
you're fine showing interest uh although
Gran thinks it's more of a game so I
have to say don't use emojis or
backwards smiley faces simple backwards
backwards smiley Jack does the
parentheses oh yeah no no it's colon
parentheses Jacks 100 I agree with that
okay well I was initially like that I
was initially a call in parentheses
person but then I was critiqued by it
and made fun of it right it was a long I
don't even remember who it was but it
was back in like Middle School someone's
like you write your smiley face this is
like basket they're messy no they
weren't no they weren't because they
would send them the other one way to me
and ever since then ever since I was
made fun of it if they were wrong you
were right the entire time and you
doubted yourself
yeah man look at me now and deleting all
the apps yeah didn't work so that's it
deleted the apps I want to you know if I
end up you know eventually meeting a
girl I want to ideally approach them in
person I don't think there's anything
wrong in you know with dating apps and I
will maintain that but I'd love to meet
him in person but now we're going to
talk about what it's really like to meet
Mr Beast in person what is Warehouse is
like his offices Dave Ramsey and Darman
their headquarters honestly might be
more impressive yeah I gotta say we
first went to Mr BEAST's headquarters
he's so nice by the way it was amazing
because we we flew in we stayed at this
hotel that was way too expensive it's
like 250 a night
overpriced but anyway we get there 250 a
night like for a last minute trip I
don't think that's that oh it wasn't
last minute
yeah it was it was a little bit last
minute yeah I wouldn't say it was I
wouldn't say it was like it was like a
motel six or something like that okay
for a Motel 6 yeah it was not like a
like a Ritz Carlton by any means it was
in the Motel 6 it was a Marriott that's
fair that's reasonable it was like the
Marriott Gardens
area it doesn't matter if it's like a it
was a fine experience but anyway we show
up there it's incredible because we
showed up to his his whole warehouse and
I'm like this is a you like a YouTuber
is working here like what do you mean
what do you mean you wouldn't expect it
from someone who makes YouTube videos
like it's so massive the amount of land
that he has and building space that he
has in this new Warehouse is enormous
for his buildings like branded at all or
no no also one thing you forgot to
mention is the morning when we woke up
the first day we were gonna go visit the
headquarters we he actually sent someone
like a driver to go to come pick us up
what so we had our own driver that
picked us up in a Mercedes drove us to
the headquarters and while we were on
our way there it was just like tons of
planes and field and there was a house
that was just sliced in half sitting in
the middle of like a grassy field a
massive grassy field and we're like that
has to be Mr Beast project right like
yeah that's a project we're working on
right now video is up right now and then
we pull up to the headquarters and it's
just a massive what was it like half a
million square feet of Warehouse no no I
don't think no that was Dave Ramsey Dave
Ramsey was happening yeah yeah I don't
know how big his was it was big though
it was massive it was massive yeah is
this the one where he filmed the
interview with Colin and Samir right yes
yeah what is all that space even being
utilized all of it really yeah it's
incredible but when you walk into the
warehouse you have office space and then
you walk further Beyond and it's just
like a big open space with different
sets and there are multiple different
sets and there's like 50 people working
just they're all doing something they're
all there and what I found remarkable is
that we're talking about like where to
set up and stuff and they said How's
this chair how's this how's this all
right perfect well we'll have that all
set up for you and then like 20 minutes
later it's set up they had like six
production assistants that were working
basically the entire time just making
sure basically for you yes yeah like
they they let us use their SD cards they
let us like use their camera equipment
they were maintaining everything you
know what's funny when you guys came
back Graham's like oh yep got the
footage right here and he has like a
little envelope with like all the SD
cards and I'm like that's funny that he
just gives you the SD cards because like
on our neck of the woods if you come
like film with us we'll be like oh by
the way uh bring your SD card or we'll
be like oh wait let's transfer the
footage because you can't take our eyes
yeah because we only have like we only
have a few yeah Lexar finally sent us
some shout out to Lexar the official
card sponsor they they finally sent us
some but for so long ram was using like
this brokennessd card this one he has
one and it's broken and I'm like Alex I
need that back he's like I need he's
like transfer the footage I need it back
meanwhile you guys are over at Mr B's
complex living it up and they just give
USD cards yeah so
walk me through it because I was shocked
he lives in his studio is did I hear
that right yeah and so he has a room in
his massive Warehouse which also has a
kitchen like a Community Kitchen where
you can just walk in grab snacks for
free yeah we ate for free free coffee
there was a massive like industrial
grade refrigerator that was just stocked
oh yeah it's always stock bunch of
different beverages it was incredible
any drink you could want was in that
fridge did they have uh
vegetables should be bars I don't know
they had tons of primes oh they had a
ton of pro they were stocked every
flavor probably I think they even had
like a new flavor I'm like I didn't even
know that was out oh is it the meta Moon
flavor I don't know what it was it was
it was just some like really colorful
flavor I'm like yeah it was great but it
is insane I would never leave the
warehouse
I think he designed it that way so he
didn't have to leave right so do you
think now I was hearing also that he
said in an interview I think in your
interview or maybe a bunch of other
interviews that for him he just works
till he's burnt out
is that similar to you ground because
that sounded kind of familiar I don't
think there's anything wrong with that I
like it no I knew Whoa man why are you
getting so defensive
I agreed I just said those words really
sounded familiar and I was like is that
similar something something that you do
I guess so kind of
um
you think so yeah I think Mr BEAST's
intensity of working is jacked up a
little bit and his intensity of taking
breaks is also jacked up a little bit
like he'll just take an entire day
Hiatus where he just sits in his room
and watches anime for like 24 hours
straight he said and then he'll just get
right back into working but Graham's a
little bit more balanced with it yeah
yeah I don't think I could take a full
day off but I could do a half day but I
won't work as much as he does during the
days that he's on usually I'll try to
cut it off
yeah but it's still pretty like yeah it
depends on the day but yeah he will
outwork me absolutely how did you land
This and like how do you convince Mr B
sit down with you yeah so I had a
meeting with David and Ezra from night
media uh who work with Mr Beast and oh I
was like yeah we had a launch together
and um I mentioned that I wanted to do
do these interviews and he said oh you
should reach out to Mr Beast
yeah and he said I'm pretty sure if you
ask him he'll say yes and I was honestly
like I didn't like I felt like I didn't
want to bother him or like why would he
want to do it for me like as an example
you have a lot of people's contacts yeah
and when I see them on Instagram and I
see they're in Vegas I always tell
Graham oh this person's in Vegas and
Graham's like I don't want to I don't
want to bother them I'm like no so some
of the time I do reach out I do
sometimes you do but I'm just saying
he's very uh if he reached out every
time that like we sent some things he'd
be reaching out like all the time but so
you were just weary of reaching out to
him because you didn't want to
waste his time right right I didn't want
to ask for something if I felt like it
was a overreach or like you know just I
wanted to be respectful of of him and
his time and uh but anyway he said if
you ask he'll say yes and so I got home
and I just sent a message and pretty
quickly afterwards he's like yeah I'm
down coordinate with my manager and if
he could find a time I'm in and so then
the rest of the two weeks I think it
took like two weeks to set up with his
manager because his schedule is so
sporadic like he doesn't know what's
what's like every day there's a lot of
flexibility and he's so busy that he
can't guarantee that I'm going to be
free at this time and so we got a small
window where he's like okay we could
we're pretty sure we could do this day
or this day and then as it got closer he
says all right we could do this day but
we're not exactly sure what time we
could film it'll be sometime that day so
we got there at like eight o'clock in
the morning is that compound yeah to him
all right and we set up all day just
expecting that whenever he's free
he's free and we could do this and I
think we started filming around 6 p.m so
we were there all day but that was I had
so much fun just being there during the
day and getting to talk to his team
because everyone is like an a player
like everyone is the best at what they
do he doesn't hire anybody who's just
like average everyone is is so expert in
everything that they do and so just
meeting his team is super cool and then
he came in we started filming such a
nice guy very laid back
you know and and I was very conscious
too of his time because he was I think
he still is working out every single day
and so he said that he has to play a
soccer and work out afterwards and I was
just really respectful like I didn't
want to go over but he was cool with it
he was like no no we could keep going we
just kept going it was amazing and we
were there I think uh until like
midnight or something like that no we
weren't there till midnight we were
there until like like 10 and no but then
and then we did soccer and then we came
back yeah
so you weren't you but you were
basically with him Tillman yeah yeah I
got you yeah really nice guy overall
fantastic experience thumbs up would
recommend so what did it what's the Dirt
Guns did the employees truly look like
they were happy yes yeah oh God yeah and
there I don't know how the hours work
but you see some people who are just
working really late and then when we got
in really early I mean people are just
like walking in while it seems like
they're just working their own hours but
they work a lot of hours because they
really enjoy it like everybody is is
Thoroughly just invested they seem
inspired and that they agree with the
mission that Mr Beast has which is to
become as big as possible on YouTube and
make the best videos possible it was
really incredible everyone's really
young too like I would say I I I'm just
guessing probably 18 25. he has older
employees oh yeah a majority of them are
younger yeah but like go-getters like
really motivated young people who are
just experts so does he have like
in-house people that feel build these
sets like he must right oh those are
contractors actually oh he does okay
yeah so the people that build the sets
that's all just like Woodworkers and
stuff that are on contract yeah that's
incredible
and then Dave Ramsey which we did like a
week or two what two weeks later or
something like that so we left Mr Beast
and we're like this can't get any better
this I was visiting my family during
that time I so I did not go to this but
yeah yeah tell me how that went Dave
Ramsey we pull up and we we see like off
this building after off this building
after off like huge places and it's all
owned by Dave Ramsey he had half a
million square feet yeah all right so
again my first question is
how the heck did we land there because I
know a little bit of the story and I
know that that was like
kind of just things lined up how did you
get how did you get in contact with Dave
and his team
and how the heck he doesn't do collabs
with anybody so how did you convince him
yeah so it was George Campbell works
with Dave Ramsey he's one of the
personalities and he reacted to a video
that I posted I think it was an old Tick
Tock or something like that that I had
posted he reacted to it and said that
even though we disagree with debt uh
we're on the same page about saving
money living below our means all of that
and uh then I posted a response video we
started talking on Instagram and then he
said hey you know we're going to be in
Las Vegas uh speaking if you guys want
to show up I'll get you three tickets
you know like the peace Universe
financial piece yeah yeah so we show up
there and
um I'm surprised just like you know how
nice everybody was there we just sit in
and it's this huge space uh I don't know
maybe 5 000 people could have sat in
this place and we sit down we watched
Dave speak and Dave was a great speaker
afterwards I go and talk to uh George I
take a picture with him and he mentions
like you know maybe we could get you to
Tennessee if you want to come and we
could see what we could do and we just
kept in touch and sure enough the timing
worked out we flew down there but it was
through George we were able to make that
happen
yeah and Dave's Place was on honestly a
whole other level yes like so you're
saying that Dave Ramsey's place was on a
different level than yesterday it was
more impressive yeah oh my gosh by
significantly up by tenfold yeah why it
was like what set it apart it was like a
hospital like it was so clean it was
massive there was like a huge open floor
plan with an indoor Auditorium that just
opened up into like countless rooms like
restaurants and inside yeah it's what's
really interesting that I had no idea is
that if you're a fan of the Dave Ramsey
show you could just show up and walk
into his headquarters and you can they
have this so where they filmed the Dave
Ramsey show there's a massive glass wall
and you can sit outside of the recording
studio and just watch as a fan and they
play it on this TV and you can also
watch through this screen because
they're watching it happen live what as
they're filming it yeah and and then
Dave Ramsey after he finishes whatever
segment maybe the debt free scream or
something like that he'll always walk
out Shake everyone's hand take photos
talk with people no and then he just
walks right back in and then everyone
just watches them through this big glass
screen and there weren't even that many
people there maybe 25. yeah if that
they're all young families a lot of kids
but they just sit there and watch I
thought it was amazing but his team also
is so just you're good they're all like
again a players everyone that works
there is really aligned with his mission
and they're just like you could tell
they're they're thorough they're precise
they care
um no one's sloppy and just you could
tell the cleanliness when you walk in
there even the corridors like when you
go down the side staircase and stuff
that are usually kind of like they smell
like pee these places were Immaculate
like everything was cleaned It's amazing
And they also if you go there and you
want to watch the show live everyone
gets a free coffee as well so you're
saying go there for the free coffee go
there for the free coffee and the
entertainment yeah so how many employees
does over a thousand yeah
something like that 1200 old time and
that's not remote that's in person so
what do you think separates Dave from Mr
Beast in that terms do you think he's
just had so much time to teach yeah uh
to really like because my guess is and
you guys correct me if I'm wrong it
sounds like Dave has this um more
corporate structure but still like a
Google right it's not like a old and
outdated structure sounds like it's more
modern but there's still structure um
and it sounds like Mr Beast since his
probably employees are much younger
um they're kind of more laid back and
prefer like the
come in whenever you want but get
everything day was very structured so I
have a feeling people get there they
clock in at eight they clock out at five
but what was interesting too is we got
picked up that morning we show up and
there's like a really nice brand new
Cadillac Escalade that's there to pick
us up we get in the car and we're
talking to the uh what was the head of
the security yeah and uh apparently like
he had worked his way up with Dave for
over what was it over a decade like he
started off helping him with certain
things he worked really hard and just
like over the years just kept you know
one-upping the ranks as Dave grew this
guy grew as well and they were just side
by side the guy was so thankful for all
the opportunities that Dave gave him but
he stuck with him and uh just along the
way kept advancing it just incredible
story for him too well I'm sure they
must have an entire security team
because considering that you guys were
saying that it's public yeah um you know
what here's here's when you could tell
there's good Securities when you don't
notice the security I I guarantee we
walked through probably who knows how
many like you know people and and
civilian clothes and whatnot secretly
that's that's the security you want look
I think if you have the other kind of
security that's very uh
notable or whatever uh it draws more
attention sometimes yeah you don't want
yeah sometimes it's to deter anything
from happening because if you see
someone like that like apparently uh
Bill Gates is always tailed by like two
to three people in civilian clothes and
you have no idea if there's any security
like he wouldn't you wouldn't see it but
that's to draw us attention if you see
some security guards like what that Bill
Gates
you know but it depends on the situation
so what's up with these interviews man
because I've noticed that on your main
Channel we're posting more interviews
we're interviewing more large creators
about uh how they're running their
operations how to go how they got to
where they are you planning on stopping
the the normal market update videos oh
God or what's the plan I want to do like
at least one a month because I think
that would be a lot of fun but yeah I've
been making a list every time I I think
of someone that I'd like to have for a
video I write it down now on my phone I
have probably 20 names very few people
get back to me but they're big names
like Tony Hawk was one of them I'm like
imagine we could get Tony Hawk Stevo
would be another one
um you know what I mean how can we not
have Stevo's car I feel like we know
somebody who knows Steve here's the
thing I bet I could rattle off a few of
these names and someone watching would
would have a connection
let's do it you know what they're
getting a first sneak peek of who might
be I don't want to tell everybody okay
um but a few of them I would love
Anthony Padilla would absolutely love
that
um let's see
I'll get rid of some of the big names
here Justin Bieber
yeah just Justin Bieber's on there Stevo
would be amazing Gordon Ramsay would be
incredible Dave Grohl
uh Dave Chappelle Trey Parker from South
Park he would be the one for me I I
think from all of the names Trey Parker
for me would be the most surreal
so if anyone has a connection to Trey
Parker or Matt Stone either one of them
would be fantastic uh a few of them have
actually got back to us I don't want to
name who but um actually we could bleep
it out I'll just get your reaction
no way yeah
I almost broke the chair
uh he said yes but just around his
schedule after Thanksgiving so I don't
know when but I don't want to jinx it
because the thing is with with people
like that the schedule will change
if we get that's guys that's big you
know what go to Graham's main challenge
they're probably already subscribed
they're watching the podcast yeah I'm
excited with that yeah but I was shocked
I just sent the DM and within like an
hour I got a response that's amazing I
love that yeah wow but yeah Trey Parker
Tony Hawk would be like my top tier I
would love to do that so if you guys
have connections to them Stevo too
that's the draw of us well look Johnny
Knoxville as well so if if any of you
watching have a direct connection and
you think they're open to doing it just
reach out
um you could send me a DM as well and
I'll be uh I'll be taking a look at
those send everybody
just get it to us if you have a sincere
connection DM me Alex everybody uh Jack
doesn't check his DMS but um but me or
Alex do I have an interesting story so I
was coming into work here to review with
corn and uh there's this truck that
pulls up to the driveway and it's this
huge like freight truck and um I the guy
I see him going to the door and I'm like
oh like uh what are you delivering he's
like oh he's like uh I got a pallet uh
fitness equipment and I'm like
Graham has a gym right down the road why
would he order fitness equipment and so
um I I knock on the door and I and I get
Graham and I'm like Graham where do you
want this guy to put your fitness
equipment and he's like what are you
talking about and I'm like there's a
pallet an entire pallet of fitness
equipment it weighs over like a thousand
pounds and um he's confused and then he
remembers
no
liver King reached out and said if I was
available today so liver King who was on
the podcast who's trying to get Graham
to train for like a barbarian or
something he ordered an entire palette
of fitness equipment to his house and we
had no place to put it so it's sitting
in his driveway yeah we gotta open it I
had no idea what's inside of it so I
wanted to wait for you to be here Jack
uh because maybe you put some of it in
the back of your car or something you
gotta go through it I have no clue
what's in it I'm excited yeah I'll take
some weights off your desk soon we'll
see I don't know I'm just kidding I mean
the guy the guy had to crate it in it's
on a palette yeah I had to arrange for
the shipping they like they contacted me
I got a call and and they were like hey
this is uh you know where do you live or
do you confirm this shipping address and
I was like for what and they're like oh
it's the weights and I'm like oh my God
because I remember liver King said he
would send us some and I was like holy
cow I'm like yeah sure send it to send
this to the address yeah we'll put it
here what it is but we'll go through
so on the topic of liver King gotta say
I still am shook he gave me this watch
and he gave Graham an amazing necklace
and it's so surreal I had not a necklace
what is it called chain I have never
received a gift as generous as the watch
that he gave me and I don't think you've
received a gift as generous as the chain
he gave you right uh in terms of the
dollar amount Grant Navarre gave me the
uh the Rolex datejust though true dial
that was that was a substantial gift I
do wear that often yeah yeah yeah but I
mean just the sheer generosity of liver
King is unparalleled and on top of that
he wants us to go fly to his house in
Texas where we can do a barbarian with
him and the city wants us to like live
like he does for like a couple days I
think that would be so fun I I would
love to make a video but I think I think
Graham has to get really ahead but I
think I should be a weekend so we did
yeah Friday leave on a Sunday I think
that would be cool and I would probably
lose
yeah it'd be good yeah I'm excited
because a barbarian sounds incredibly
difficult I honestly do not think I
could do it in my current shape it's 70
pound kettlebells in each hand I think a
120 pound backpack 20 pound ankle
weights on each ankle and you're
dragging a 120 or so pound sled you have
to walk a mile so even just like the
kettlebells in each hand 70 pounds just
sounds like extremely challenging
curious about do they adjust for your
weight because you weigh more than I do
and the percentage of me carrying two
you know 70 pound kettlebells is
significantly more than you doing I
don't think they adjust for that yeah I
don't think which I agree I mean the
same goes for me in liver King it's I
mean liver King has a incredible you
know way to advance but I feel like it
should be like between a height and
weight perspective that significantly
more weight than for most people but he
also had his like 16 or 17 year old yeah
but still this kid is taller than I am
yeah yesterday I did train a little bit
like I or not sorry not yesterday it was
probably about a few days ago I grabbed
70 pound dumbbells and I tried walking
with them it was like starting to like
pull at my skin granted the weights had
very like grippy rips which kind of
weren't the greatest kettlebells would
be better but it's still extremely
challenging just like walking you know
50 feet with 70 pound kettle or
dumbbells in each hand
I don't I don't think I could do it no
I'm worried about adjusting for weight
though that's all is you wouldn't put
someone who's like you know 90 pounds
let's just say they wouldn't do this at
those weights
so where's the cut off between like hey
we should adjust down a little bit
I think it should be based on a
percentage take it up with liver King
yeah I mean what he's got to say about
that yeah I don't think he's gonna
adjust the weight
that's all I got I think we just gotta
train really hard yeah
yeah guys you know what's been blowing
up my tick tock
let's try guys have you heard about the
try guys and the cheating skin I heard
about it oh Jack oh do you know about it
yeah I heard about it okay why is it
everywhere on my like normally we don't
talk about this stuff but why is it
everywhere on my feed and you guys think
that that all publicity is good I mean
it really depends on the kind of
audience that you have and your end goal
if your end goal is to attract as much
attention as possible probably yeah but
if your end goal is to try to gain uh
like a network of really devoted
supporters and stuff like that probably
not yeah what was the example where Will
Smith slapped Chris Rock what was that
on
what do you mean what was that on what
was that the thing called I mean oh the
the Oscars the Oscars the Oscars had
seen declining viewership for years and
that was the one of their most viewed
episodes ever brought a lot of attention
back to it but because of a negative
event but I'm sure they could say hey we
could turn this into a pilot we got more
eyeballs in this the people watching the
next one could be an all-time high
because you're going to want to wait and
see you're going to pay off some actors
slap someone else yeah what's gonna
happen no I think out of them obviously
that's a good thing but we're talking
like about Will Smith getting a lot of
publicity from that probably not a very
good oh yeah he's he's ruined his image
but Chris Rock by the way sold he sold
out sold out yeah yeah everyone's like
is he gonna talk about is it so I mean
it depends I think for this it's
probably not the attention that
they want but they could probably spin
it in such a way where they make it a
positive in a weird way but
people are thirsty for stuff right now
man it's just like they want they want
something to latch on dude drama and I
feel like anything right now is just
they want to focus on something it just
happened to be that final thought which
I think is kind of an interesting topic
Graham finally listened to me which is a
good thing what do you say Jack I said
actually he got you because I actually
get you yeah you did uh because he's he
sent out an application to hire an
assistant editor which I think is a
fantastic idea basically what happened
if I'm understanding this correct Graham
posted on his story right sent out an
application for people for an assistant
editor and he directed everyone to your
inbox on Instagram and basically you're
you were supposed to try to find someone
to hopefully if you were ever out if
Graham was unable to edit a video
someone that's like a second string
editor yeah which I think is a fantastic
idea I think if any YouTuber who's
making the amount of money that Graham's
making with the responsibility and the
output that Graham has I think it's
really important to have fail safes
especially you know when it's such a low
cost to try to just train somebody to
edit a video I feel like that's a very
reasonable and good business decision
I'm proud of Graham I think you did the
right thing there I agree so we'll see
we'll see how it is but uh but yeah I
think having a backup is a good idea I
mean worst case I'm just gonna edit
myself so but it'll be good if Alex goes
out because all every single time Alex
like hey Graham I'm going out of town
this week
when was the last time I was on the
weekends or something I try I try not to
go out of town
because I try to
I try to man The Post Jack I think
you've been there's been a few times but
we've always been able to work around it
because Alex will tell me and then they
say okay well then I'll work in advance
and we'll get some videos done and
usually it's only like one day though
like aside from weekend usually it'll be
like a Friday or something I think you
went to Wisconsin too and that was a
month ago
I thought the cruise was for quite a few
days yeah that's the only other time
that I've taken time off in Wisconsin no
and you went to California that one week
I took one day out I These are times
where we we were all gone you guys I
will say the only time that I did uh
when when you guys were here was when I
went
cruise but that was when I first got
hired yeah you got hired you started
working and the next year you're like
all right guys going on a cruise
the next year no it was like literally
no it was literally like I think like
four months uh after I think I was like
I think I got hired or something but
anyways I think it's a good idea you're
hiring it's like it's like an editor you
know there's a word for this
but you know Outsource is uh it's a
great thing I'm I'm in full support of
it it was funny I was at an event or a
conference I guess whatever convention a
couple weeks ago vid Summit and a lot of
people came up to me and they said some
of their favorite discussions I know you
guys may be extremely sick of it are the
Outsourcing versus not Outsourcing stuff
and uh I just thought that was really
funny to hear because my idea on it was
everyone was super sick of it I'm not
going to continually bring it up because
I understand you know don't beat a dead
horse but it was just interesting to
hear that that was some people's
favorite uh segments they looked forward
Graham is still like holding his ground
though because I got when I got the
submissions back for the 80 of them 90
of them one were remote I did mention a
grandma I was like you know Graham for
like a backup better it'll be fine and
Rick Graham's like no got a tight
operation we keep it that way and Alex
has been doing fantastic with title
thumbnails too oh I gotta say I've been
getting back yeah we brainstormed for a
good 30 minutes 60 Minutes every video
and usually between the both of us we'll
bounce ideas back and forth and Alex is
uh you know really picking up it took it
took a while anyways guys thank you so
much for tuning in to this midweek
episode it's been an amazing
conversation with two very close friends
of mine Alex and Graham here on the jack
Selby show by the way guys What shirt
are you wearing this shirt you may have
noticed I look extremely overdressed
yeah turns out I'm not this is as
comfortable as maybe a pajama top yeah
but it looks extremely nice I would wear
this a on a date be a business meeting
see if I was going for a jog in the park
or D sleeping it's also it's waterproof
I would have done nothing waterproof but
it actually gets out wrinkles yeah if
you're walking around in it because of
some crazy material it's made out of
literally I'm not even using hyperbole
when I'm saying this the comfiest shirt
I've ever won in my entire life Rhone
they sponsored the last podcast episode
and I just want to say because I've been
like continually wearing their shirts
that they sent us since the last podcast
episode and I've been loving them in
fact I went out with my housemates last
night and like four of us wore our own
shirts so I'm not even I'm not even
kidding I'll throw up a photo right now
we went to Tony's Mexican food that's
absolutely crazy because like I've been
using Lexar cards okay thank you so much
money too because I by the way
public.com Graham by the way guys if you
want to check out Roan for yourself
there's a link Down Below in the
description you can get probably some
sort of discount with our code so thank
you Roan thank you everyone for watching
see you guys next time till next time
let's see what's in that liver King
thing